he may not solve the nostalgic appeal of
Toby Maguire or the youthful energy of
Tom Holland but Andrew Garfield still
did a great job bringing Spider-Man to
life so why were the Amazing Spider-Man
movies canceled after two movies and is
a series gone for good
when Sony made the decision to cancel
some Remy Spiderman 4 and move forward
with a reboot they probably had a grand
plan to keep the franchise going for a
while about a year after the release of
the Andrew Garfield starring Amazing
Spider-Man in 2012 the studio announced
that ambitious later follow-ups The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 had already been
greenlit and was well underway the flags
were also planted for two more films to
be released in 2016 and 2018. the
release of The Amazing Spider-Man 2 in
2014 didn't meet expectations though it
was Savage by critics and earned
significantly less than his predecessor
which itself had already been a steep
decline from Remy's Spider-Man 3 in 2007
unsure of how to write the ship Sony's
Amy Pascal made the unprecedented
decision to not only scrap plans for the
sequels but to team up with Marvel
Studios and firmly established
Spider-Man as part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this resulted in a
complete Erasure of The Amazing
Spider-Man series halting a third
installment and replacing Andrew
Garfield with Tom Holland Spider-Man
though Garfield may have already been on
the outs with rumors of his firing even
before the reboot the series was left
off on something of a cliffhanger for
audiences who now had to wonder if
they'd ever get closure and prior to
Garfield's return in Spider-Man no way
home there unfortunately didn't seem to
be a way forward for a three-qual
whatever I don't know I tried to think
about it how's that working out for you
perfectly
over the years just about everyone
involved in The Amazing Spider-Man and
its sequel has been asked about the
third film even after Marvel Studios
transported Andrew Garfield's version of
Peter Parker into the MCU it's a
question that's been posed to much of
the cast Sally Field wasn't thrilled by
the idea she was apparently uninterested
in reprising her role as Aunt May field
admitted in 2016. it's really hard to
find a three-dimensional character in it
Dane Dahan who played Harry Osborne
seemed to feel differently when asked
about rumors of his appearance in
Spider-Man their way home the actor told
radio times I would certainly love to
make some kind of movie like that again
as for Andrew Garfield himself he
studied happily done the spandex again
thus only under the right circumstances
in 2022 he told the happy sad confused
podcast I am definitely open to that it
would have to be something very unique
very special and of service to the
audience of service to the character in
2016 the MCU introduced a newer younger
Peter Parker played by Tom Holland and
Captain America civil War an instant fun
favorite it seemed that audiences had no
problem saying goodbye to Andrew
Garfield and The Amazing Spider-Man
universe this was further cemented by
the enormous success of Spider-Man
homecoming and Spider-Man far from home
the latter of which was the first film
for the wall crawler to pass a billion
dollars at the box office but Garfield
thought he wasn't beloved in that role
he must have had a shock when he was
asked to make a surprise appearance and
Spider-Man no way home joining forces
with both Tom Holland and Toby Maguire's
versions of the web Slinger Garfield
made his Triumph from return and the fan
response was overwhelming in fact
multiple fun petitions popped up on
change.org encouraging sonita green
lights The Amazing Spider-Man 3.
including one that totaled more than 30
000 signatures I love you guys
2022 a former Marvel lawyer spoke to
animated times and said that legally
speaking there was nothing standing in
the way of Sony jumping back into the
Amazing Spider-Man franchise but while
Sony hasn't commented officially on the
prospect of returning to that series of
films it now seems like a third Amazing
Spider-Man can be a real possibility
after years of hopelessness
by the end of The Amazing Spider-Man 2
Gwen Stacy is dead leaving Peter Parker
to deal with his grief and guilt without
her as seen near the end of the film
tease the host of new villains and of
Dane dehan's Green Goblin now knowing
Spider-Man's true identity it seemed
they were setting up some major new
story lines director Mark Webb told den
of geek in 2017 we were talking about
the Sinister Six Chris Cooper was going
to come back and play the Norman Osborne
Goblin we were going to freeze his head
and then he was going to be brought back
to life could all of that still happen
anything is possible but with more than
10 years since the film's release it's
just as likely that something new would
be dreamed up if it was up to Andrew
Garfield it would be very different from
Webb's initial plans while speaking with
a happy sad confused podcast Garfield
seems more excited about the notion of
facing off with Tom Hardy's anti-hero
Venom considering the Multiverse
Shenanigans introduced in their way home
the possibilities for a third film are
practically endless it might be easy to
assume that a third Amazing Spider-Man
film would simply bring back the cast of
the two previous entry series but that's
not quite as simple as it might sound
for starters Emma Stone probably
wouldn't be back when Stacy died at the
climax of the previous movie after all
plus with more than a decade having
already passed since the Amazing
Spider-Man 2 not everyone may be Keen to
reprise their roles with several new
entries in Sony's own corner of the
Spider-Man universe including Venom
morbius and Craven the hunter New
Opportunities could present themselves
we've already seen the villains lizard
and Electro make a return in their way
home and they could return as either
allies or enemies as a dangerous threat
emerges there are plenty more characters
to choose from some Hardy's Venom
Michael Keaton's vulture BJ Novak's
Alistair Smythe or even Paul giamatti's
rhino
another route might be for a sequel to
feature in all new supporting Caster
Spider-Man faces off against an entirely
new enemy that we've yet to see on
screen this might be the smartest way to
go in order to help the series separate
itself from its previous lackluster
installments to say that the first two
Amazing Spider-Man films were divisive
among fans and critics would be
something of an understatement while
Andrew Garfield Emma Stone and the rest
of the film's cast were large he prays
for their performances both movies are
met with criticism from reviewers for
their half-baked overly complicated
plots some even felt that the creators
of the films didn't even understand the
character of Spider-Man but their Grim
dark takes on the source material not
gelling with many longtime fans of the
comics the overwhelming fun response to
Garfield's return in their way home
proves as a clear appetite for more
stories set in that Universe though and
the third film would be an opportunity
for Sony to finally do it right it would
also be their chance to prove that they
can make a great live-action Spider-Man
film on their own without some Remy or
Marvel Studios the same way they did an
animation with into the spider-verse a
new story could also fix mistakes with
the past such as the death of Gwen Stacy
or the awkward new interpretation of the
Green Goblin with the introduction of
the Multiverse for example we could meet
a Gwen Stacy from another reality maybe
even a live-action Spider Guy in Not
only would this allow Emma Stone to
reappear Against All Odds but it would
also provide a tangible way for
Garfield's version of Peter Parker to
come face to face with the grief and
pain caused by her death drawing
Spider-Man no way home we learned that
the past several years have been pretty
hard on Andrew Garfield's Pizza Parker
after losing Gwen Stacy Peter was unable
to forgive himself and while he tried to
keep on being a friendly neighborhood
hero he actually turned into a much
darker angrier character at some point I
just I start pulling my punches
I got rageful thankfully the events of
no way home helped Garfield's traumatize
hero to heal and the actor believes his
character will be very different the
next time we see him in the official art
book for no way home Garfield elaborates
a bit on this saying he's going back
knowing that he has Brothers he's going
back in re-inspired to follow his
Destiny his calling the purpose of his
life by catching MJ he got to make up
for a terrible tragedy that he tried to
avoid in his world Garfield also
believes that Peter had his eyes open so
the mysteries of the Multiverse
explaining I think he's going back with
a mind blown about the cosmos and the
universe and string theory and multiple
dimensionality he's going back
incredibly reinvigorated if we ever get
to see this version of pizza back in his
world he probably won't be hitting the
bad guys quite as hard as he might be
trying to dig deeper into the Multiverse
For Better or For Worse considering that
Marvel Studios is moving full steam
ahead of more films on their own
Spider-Man series starring Tom Holland
one might wonder how they react to Sony
embarking on a separate Journey with a
wall crawler from the past back when the
deal to bring Spider-Man into the MCU
was first being struck Marvel's Kevin
feige had no interest in continuing the
series Sony had honcho Amy Pascal had
apparently always intended for Amazing
Spider-Man 3 to follow the deal with
Marvel Studios just with more direct
input from them to ensure success it was
feige who forced Sony's hand to reboot
the franchise rather than bring Andrew
Garfield into the fold today given
Marvel's success with the Multiverse
with variants of the same character can
co-exist with audiences clearly
appreciating multiple stories living
side by side figure Marvel may not be as
opposed as you might think at least not
if you ask Colin who clearly has no room
for jealousy the actor told
comicbook.com I would love to see The
Amazing Spider-Man 3. I think what was
so wonderful was how Andrew Garfield was
able to kind of make amends of the
character and the studio you know it's a
kind of win the general public back so
should Sony decide to do that they would
have my full support and obviously so
would Andrew
who are you
[Music]
Spider-Man
foreign